hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play affected an
absolutely phenomenally looking oculus
rift horror game I'm not even gonna
bother explaining because I don't know a
damn thing about it
all I know is that holy hell this looks
awesome compared to what I usually play
on these which is just minor experiences
this could be fantastic so there's three
different levels I'm just gonna set the
full experience and go for it and I
accidentally almost started it by
looking at that thing to call the lift
over but anyway let's get to it
oh I'm dot tickles I'm got tickles okay
let's go blip yeah it's good it did haha
okay excuse me
okay oh that's what that was okay it's
all gluey glue back there I just wasn't
sure what it was I got to make sure that
I get the full experience out of this
Wow that was in my right here okay so I
got my gamepad but it's not an official
gamepad it's like one of those ones you
gave your friends when you were when you
really hated them and so okay that's
coming okay where am I good why why am i
twisting okay I
dad is really cool by the way oh my this
is some strange depth of field going on
here with the oculus rift because I got
a bunch of layers going on here do not
enter this experiment lightly if you
feel unwell remove the headset
immediately okay this is gonna be one of
those nightmare elevators isn't it oh
these are lovely pictures this is your
family the manor that's the name of the
first level this is all called affected
I don't know how long this game might be
but it actually might be a pretty pretty
interesting experience okay so I got my
gamepad here what nope I don't
oh I gotta use the arrow buttons okay
that's unusual well maybe I can this is
I gotta use the arrow buttons it's like
oh this is like the Mad Catz controller
that you really don't want to use but
I'm using it so I don't know you know
why I didn't get a regular Windows Xbox
controller I just said like hey this one
looks cool and it's like the worst
ergonomically that you could possibly
get your hands turn into claws as you're
holding it oh well whatever that's
besides the point I missed something
already where their doors that I was
supposed to go in I don't know dude look
at the detail on this ah it's amazing oh
I've been so lucky to find these really
good any horror games that I've lately
besides oh when I played yesterday of
course but you know so far so good this
one looks like so much work has been
hello someone's swinging up in a door
particle effects okay all right I got to
remember that I can actually look around
here oh oh whoo gee bored
oh are you say are you n run Oh run Oh
ha okay I'm gonna run over here oh I
feel good you look good for me Oh gonna
be fantastic
okay is that just me or does that look
like a screaming face on the walls does
that look like a shadow silhouette of a
little girl with a bear I'm not just
seeing things like oh that looks like a
okay nevermind I've doing Rorschach
tests on the walls I'm gonna get out of
here wait a minute this has changed
something is severely changed here this
is ah I love the oculus rift I cannot
wait for the retail version of the
oculus rift with the higher resolution
because I mean a lot of people complain
when they watch the videos outside of it
that it's like you know it's not that
great and you're right the resolution is
1280 by 800 it's not that fantastic but
you got to remember what you're seeing
is only half of it because you're only
seeing half of it because I have to
split the video in half because when it
displays its two videos side by side one
for each eye and then I have to split
and stretch it for you guys to be able
to see what's going on
how about you go after yourself
hahaha no no what is that what is that
what is that what are this what are this
what are this what are this I don't know
look look oh that's disturbing
no all right continuing forward lovely
paint on the walls
is this lead-based mmm delicious my
favorite hey Bonnie
oh you're looking good I like your
everything oh man all right
all right come on come on come on what
are ya what do ya ha not that preferably
okay
okay
bucatini gonna be like that you can
[ __ ] alright come on Oh bring it on
okay don't bring it on bring it off
bring it around
Oh
that like many of the children singsong
sing-alongs was about death
mayhem although I heard the
ring-around-the-rosie may not actually
be about Oh God that curtain scared the
crap out of me that is even worse that
turns bad within oh oh oh huh okay this
is a kid yeah what is that
there's writing on the walls how long
something something works I'll make no
my G okay I mean I want to let everyone
know that it's very early in the morning
and I'm recording in my walls aren't as
thick as I thought they were in my
soundproofing is that as good as I
thought that was so if any neighbors can
hear me
I apologize for screaming like a little
baby girl how'd you not wish to do this
this game make me do this this game make
me do stupid
okay just shelving units oh this oh is
that gonna come out a picture and come
out to me I know your tricks I know your
trick C tricks
nada tricks to take a deep breath and
enjoy the experience I like you know
I've been playing her what is that is
that a phone hi who was fun actually you
know and oh you again here have a better
look at this guy
oh that is that that is that is lovely
that is lovely or is it is that
Slenderman in the background there good
good
what's that god damn those curtains
curtains are bad you making me think we
think things
that is the most disturbing cloud is
that the original Ronald McDonald I have
no idea that's a good sound someone
taking a shower over there something I
should know about
goodness I'm a goodness gravy
all right bring it on anyway I've been
playing organs for so long you know when
I first started playing them I will
admit I have developed a bit of a
tolerance for them so I really really do
enjoy these rare experiences when you
get these freely well made one and once
again this this one totally free I mean
it's amazing what you can get out of the
indie game community and I feel like
there should be a better system to
reward developers and make stuff like
this it's amazing and not to mention the
adrenaline oh you know Peggy can we
gonna get our gonna back up slowly and
you pretend that never happened oh I got
to go down there don't I I gotta go down
there good good good
I like that but anyway like playing
horror games is actually quite fun you
will find it's just like oh it's it's uh
Richard
no thank you
I will play with you I will play every
game with you
such that you do not murder my brains
out and kill me dead prez frankly I
prefer to be alive me alive would be
great look at that look at the shadows
on the wall okay this looks like a nice
room is this gonna be uh this is gonna
be nice oh that is not gonna be nice
unless you're gonna do the dance of the
fairies with the chairs and whatnot
floating in mid-air tad is really cool
oh this is so cool ah I hope you're all
getting secondhand excitement from me
because it's just so cool oh my God look
at that it's like I can touch it it's so
cool oh my god this is exactly why along
the oculus rift to survive and it's so
excited that like I'm not gonna stand
under that by the way just in case I'm
so excited that like big names like fat
Alvin John Carmack from ID of an amazing
game program like a pioneer in gaming
he's working on the alcázar if I wanted
to succeed so badly it goes this gaming
like this is just amazing
okay so that's the Slenderman don't know
them are oh because this is
it's still spinning oh okay ooh steps
topping
ooh I see something up there I thought I
saw something up there okay
that's still spinning that's up why'd
you move why did you decide to move are
you one of those Oh you stop spinning I
hear something
you're still is burning ain't go near
you okay all right okay all right okay
sorry what Oh thought isn't me okay all
right all right all right all right okay
okay okay okay okay I'll do it you're
gonna do already shun lady okay with the
old man that I care what you do right
now
oh-oh-oh I'm completely turned how long
was I facing that way I like what oh my
god how long was how long was I facing
that direction oh my god oh my god oh my
heart what is oh my god
oh man oh that was just the first part
that's amazing I'm gonna save this one
you guys were hoping that I played
through all three of them right now I'm
gonna save them oh my goodness gravy oh
my goodness that was pure and simple
amazing by far one of the best probably
the best oculus rift game and probably
frankly that was just fantastic on a
basic level if that was just an indie or
game I would love to play that that was
incredible
I really want to know how long I was
facing over that way because I I really
can't see so how long did I look like an
idiot so anyway that was the first part
of affected there's two more parts and
you'll see them very soon so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always we'll see you in the
next video
good
you